good morning John it's Saturday and I'm
making a Saturday video because I have
some important things to say about
what's going on in my life right now
here's the main thing that's going on in
my life that's right
it's Las Vegas I'm here in Las Vegas
because a friend of mine is getting
married and a friend of mine is getting
married because she got engaged to a guy
who was in the Air Force and they were
gonna get married like a year from now
turns out though that he has to go to
Iraq so they're getting married now and
so on very short notice I have come to
Las Vegas entirely for the wedding
because as you probably remember from
the last time you and I were in Vegas I
really don't like very many things about
Las Vegas I really hate to gamble like a
lot it's just way too stressful and it
doesn't I don't understand the appeal at
all and just generally I'm not a big fan
of creating lots of reasons to use water
in a desert and they're just generally a
culture that I'm not a big fan of for
example last night I walked by a
nightclub and there were two lines in
front of the nightclub one was for
pretty girls and the other one was for
boys and girls who were not dressed
quite as skankily as the girls in the
pretty girl line I'm not even kidding
they had a guy who was choosing which
person was good enough to get in the
short line oh yes you I like your Dallas
Cowboys cheerleader outfit with your
butt hanging out you get in the short
line but you you're wearing clothes that
cover most of your body long line anyway
this is going to have to be a very quick
video but I do have one thing that I
want to talk about that is very
important if you live in or around Las
Vegas the illustrious dr. Noyes aka Bill
Martin has acquired for me a venue space
at which to have a nerdfighter gathering
that gathering will be happening at SNK
music on Sunday from 5:00 to 7:00 I'm
afraid that I'm gonna have to stick very
close to that schedule because I am here
for a wedding so yes Sunday from 5:00 to
7:00 the address and a link to a Google
map of it is in the sidebar I will have
some copies of so jokes as well as some
copies of the dftba compilation album
and everyone who comes will get a
special surprise and I'm not even gonna
tell you what it is also you should know
that if you're in Los Angeles San
Francisco San Diego or Phoenix I will
probably be in your neck of the woods
sometime soon so you might not want to
get in the car and drive a really long
way just to see me this once only to
find out that I'm gonna be like in your
backyard fairly soon and if it is this
up because it is Holly and I have the
day about my favorite Halloween thing
that has happened so far
Molly Lewis aka sweet Afton 23 dressed
up like Lady gaga
and sang poker face with a ukulele and
you can go
to that video right here John I will see
you tomorrow
[Music]